I lived in Iran for about a year and I
must say as charming and educated and
cultured by the way but I found Persians
I also found in my experience no country
which was more ethnocentric for you or
for me the time of persepolis was about
2,500 years ago I think for most of our
Persian friends it was yesterday and so
there's a great desire to again take a
major place in the world stage and I
think at least in the hearts and minds
of some in Iran and some of the
leadership the possession of nuclear
weapons is a large step up onto that
stage that given the rather difficult
rhetoric that President Ahmadinejad puts
forth particularly about the right of
Israel to exist leads me to some concern
likewise they are involved in some
mischief certainly in in Lebanon and in
Iraq and Syria which can lead to
concerns is it an immediate threat in my
view it's a longer-term threat now I
think politically with the eu3 along
with the United States being positioned
to try to work diplomatically we have
some time
the mountain view is first of all you
ought to have enough faith in your
ability to conduct diplomacy that you
can have talks even with enemies without
losing ground at the negotiating table
or as I say having them pick your pocket
besides to face-to-face discussions are
are beyond just to try to get the other
guy to have your way it's the ability to
explore the depths of your adversaries
thinking it's a possibility of there is
a possibility of getting some g2 or some
intelligence on them there are a whole
host of reasons we ought to engage I
would say with our enemies even more
than our friends